all right there he is clyde edward
zelaire kansas city chiefs 2-0 he had
exactly 100 fewer yards shireen in his
second game but uh still off to a great
start for kansas city and one of the
candidates for offensive rookie of the
year and more importantly a candidate to
win a super bowl as a rookie because he
landed on the right team however the
chiefs had their hands full in week two
the chiefs chargers game the subject of
our rewatch simple
prospect we
re-watch the game during the game days
on sunday especially the late afternoon
games i really don't have time to see
what's going on i go to the game pass
feature i watched the condensed version
this one was a little bit longer because
it went to overtime so we took a look at
them we got a few categories shireen
based upon the chiefs charges matchup
from week two best player on the field
who's your choice
well you know it's always so easy to say
patrick mahomes right they were down by
double digits but we always see patrick
mahomes bring the chief back i mean it's
expected so that was an easy answer so i
went with harrison bedkirk because i
just thought he was outstanding
and you just knew when he was kicking
the game winning field goal no matter
how many times he had to kick it and he
had to kick it three times once because
of a false start that back it up from 53
to 58
and then once because of a timeout and
then finally he kicked the game winner
but earlier in the game he also had
kicked a 58 yarder and at that point the
chiefs were down 17-6 when he kicked
that one in the third quarter tied the
the team record of nick lowery but if
they had missed that field goal at that
point where they were on the field down
17-6 i think the game was probably over
at that point so that that kick was as
big as the one in overtime and then the
30-yarder and i know hey it's only a
30-yarder randy bullock missed a
31-yarder this isn't randy bullock but
he still had to make it on the last
player regulation to send that game into
overtime so those three kicks were just
huge and i am positive he's going to be
afc special teams player of the week
because he was outstanding we probably
don't give him enough credit we talk
about justin tucker and some of the
other guys but he's one of the best
kickers in the nfl yeah i mean he's a
guy who's usually just making extra
points for the kansas city chiefs and
coincidentally he had an extra point
blocked by jerry tillery his only miss
of the day that was one that was good
there was a penalty it got pushed back
and it was blocked and that made it
seven to six early in the game but
to go 53 yards nail it
have to do it again from 58 nail it got
iced beforehand and nailed it and all
three kicks were right down the middle
there was nothing even close about it it
wasn't one of those where it looks like
it's going this way and then it comes
back that way and that was impressive i
think even if he had been iced by his
own coach jason garrett's style he would
have ended up making that 58 yarder to
win the game my best player on the field
was justin herbert the chargers
quarterback who got the nod
moments before the start of the game
tyrod taylor gets a painkilling
injection it causes a reaction he has
chest pains he ends up at the hospital
and all of a sudden justin herbert hey
grab your helmet kid you're in this kid
is phenomenal and i am stunned by
anthony lynn's reluctance to just make
him the guy because it's obvious he's
the guy it's obvious he's got it he
looks like
phillip rivers in one of those video
games where if you throw so many passes
in a row
complete you you you like you you hit a
button and the guy grows he's like this
this freakishly super-sized philip
rivers he put damien william uh wilson
excuse me on his ass he can run with
speed and and also grit determination he
didn't take a lot of big hits like joe
burrow did and he throws the ball
incredibly well and he had one play
where
he they they set up an option
and he he faked the pitch he froze frank
clark
and ran right by him and and had a nice
gain
this is a guy who can do it all he had
some incredible throws he had a great
touchdown throw to a spot where
you you had a very small margin for
error and uh and did everything that he
could to help the chargers win the game
so i think justin herbert should be the
starting quarterback that's why you
drafted him all due respect to tyrod
taylor and there's already talk that
herbert's going to start this week
because taylor isn't healthy see what
anthony lin can do to ease his way out
of this mess is to say tyrod taylor will
start when he's 100 percent and he just
will never be 100 again and by the time
he is 100 we will have forgotten about
it
yeah no doubt and mike i think that's
probably the best way to make your first
debut right your debut is to go in there
cold you don't know you haven't you
slept real well because you thought you
were going to be sitting on the bench
the other team didn't prepare for you it
was absolutely the perfect way to start
now they're going to have film on him
this week and he's going to know he's a
starting quarterback and things are
going to be a little different but he
looked fantastic in his debut i don't
know that there have been many rookies
to come in and play a first game quite
like that it was outstanding and frankly
they had a really good chance to win the
game if not for anthony anthony lynn's
decision on fourth and one to punt the
ball away and you knew patrick mahomes
was going to lead the chiefs down and
win the game
and and you know you got the panthers up
this week that's a game that that the
chargers should win especially with
christian mccaffrey out and then it's
back-to-back games on the road at tampa
bay and at new orleans and what a great
juxtaposition that is the old men
on one hand and this fresh-faced giant
who can do it all and may represent just
another example of this quarterback
position where a cluster of great guys
are emerging early in their careers all
right game they'd like to forget shireen
well it was the chief's offensive line i
mean they only allowed one sack but
patrick mahomes was beat up in that game
i mean joey bosa was on him every single
play he got knocked down seven times or
seven quarterback hits in that game they
just have to do a better job and we know
patrick mahomes is the greatest in nfl
history even in his short career of just
going backward backward backward
backward and then making the pass but if
he keeps getting hit like that he's not
going to last all season he took some
vicious hits
including the sack by joey bosa but he's
they've got to do a better job
protecting him and i know their
offensive line has changed a lot but
they've got to find something in that
offensive line to better protect him
there was a play late in the game that
impressed me and it wasn't a block from
an offensive lineman byron pringle a
receiver went back and he actually got
joey bosa with his side because you
can't go shoulder helmet or you know
forcible blow because it was a blind
side block he was going back to his line
to back to his end zone and he used like
the back of his shoulder pad and he put
bosa on his ass which was just amazing
now i think he just caught him off
balance but it still was an amazing play
it was the best block of the day and it
wasn't a block by an offensive lineman
so that underscores your point for me
it's anthony lynn you mentioned the
fourth in one play how do you not go for
it fourth and one from your own 34 when
justin herbert is getting it done and
when you're giving the ball back to
patrick mahomes and on that drive that
resulted in the 58-yard game-winning
field goal the chiefs had a fourth and
one and what did they do they went for
it and they got it and they kept
possession of the ball and they won the
game so anthony lynn you know i i love
him as a coach but man you got to be a
little more aggressive than that
especially when the you know we talked
about analytics yesterday when the other
quarterback is patrick mahomes you don't
give him the ball in overtime there's
your analytics lesson for this tuesday
and that was the patriots philosophy in
the afc championship game in overtime
we're not going to give the ball back to
patrick mahomes and let him beat us and
they didn't face any fourth downs in
that drive but they did face some third
downs and they were just they made them
and and but i'm convinced if they had
had a fourth down they would have gone
for it because they didn't want to put
the ball back in patrick mahomes hand
you have to take all of that into
account the fact that patrick mahomes
nfl mvp super bowl mvp
is opposite you and he's going to win
the game
one more thing about herbert before we
take a break and this is what convinces
me he's going to be special there was a
run late in the second quarter austin
eckler moving toward the goal line and
the play was extended and herbert ran
over toward eckler because you never
know what's going to happen ball could
come out he could decide to flip it
maybe there's someone to block i rarely
see a quarterback sprint downfield to
see what he can do to help out
usually because the quarterback knows
it's a free shot at him if he does it
but good luck taking a free shot at
justin herbert because we saw what
happened to damian wilson you may be the
one who ends up blown up not the
quarterback
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports